القضاء التركي يوسع دائره تحقيقاته بشان
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد خليل ابن المدينه المنكوبه
هاتاي نجم مع اسرته لكن بيته سيهدم ضمن
هذه البنايه المتصدعه رغم انها شيدت حديثا
هذا هو بيتي لا يمكنني الدخول الى البنايه
التي شيدت قبل 12 سنه فقط تضررت كثيرا
بسبب الزلزال وسيتم هدمها اذا كان هناك
تقصير من المقاولين والمشرفين على بنائها
فيجب ان يحاسبوا على ذلك اما الجد محمد
فقد استسلم للامر الواقع بيته الذي كان
مؤلفا من اربعه طوابق انهار وتسبب في مقتل
13 من افراد عائلته ابني اوكانتي وبنتي
وبنتي وبنتي
وابني وزوجتي اتوفوا اولاد اولاد اثنين
واحد 15 واحد 16
انتقلوا الى رحمه الله
يعني رقم 14 وكل شيء نظامي بس ايش صار صار
بناء نحو 200 شخص رهن الاعتقال فيما يجري
التحقيق مع مئات اخرين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم
في انهيار الاف المباني تحت طائله ممارسات
بناء فاسده كما طالت الاعتقالات كذلك
مسؤولا بولايه غازي عنتاب تابعا للحزب
الحاكم وقد تمتد لاخرين
98% من البنايات المتضرره بنيت وفق قوانين
قديمه للبناء لا مشكله لدي اذا تمت محاسبه
كل متورط في فساد الابنيه الاخرى الجهات
الرسميه احصت الى الان تضرر اكثر من نصف
مليون منزل بشكل كامل ما يؤشر الى طول امد
التحقيقات بشانها واتساع دائرتها
كلما تقدمت اعمال رفع اطنان الانقاذ هذه
تكشفت معها حقائق جديده بشان تجاوزات التي
طالت تشييد البنايات الامر الذي فاقم من
اضرار الزلزال وخلف عشرات الالاف من
الضحايا عبد القادر خربوش العربيه